[Musique]
une foule de curieux se retrouve au
central pas rambo midi de fin d'hiver
plusieurs sont ici pour découvrir la
cuisine du super qualité un comptoir de
plats indiens suite à de nombreux
voyages en inde
guillaume et jeff re sont tombés en
amour avec la cuisine de ce pays et en
particulier c'est ali qu'est ce que
c'est l'italie
le thalys est parfaite comme deux choses
le talent et c'est le nom d'une grande
affaire par metal mais c'est aussi le
plat le placer différents petits plats
le dominicain bus comme le tajine c'est
à la fois le contenant et le contenu à
la fois le contenant et le contenu baby
schumi c'est un repos complet du riz
certaines mains des pins
tout autour des plats de légumes soient
viande ou végétalien d'epicor c'est
vraiment un oncle ou des assiettes
vraiment tout est là dans l'équipe
plusieurs sont d'origine indienne dont
jacqueline venu étudier au québec et qui
a été étonné de retrouver certaines
saveurs de son pays à la première fois
quand je suis venu à soubey qualité
je suis allé avec mes amis et j'ai mangé
le paf badji et j'ai pleuré tellement
nostalgique et le goût c'est tellement
proches de ce qu'on a
le tenir alphonse et la cuisine fait
maison
il ya tellement tellement de choses qui
peuvent se retrouver dans un talent inné
maintenant n'importe quel produit à
laquelle tu peux penser ça pourrait se
retrouver dans un tamis
mais les plus les viandes les plus
communément manger en inde ça va être le
poulet et l'agneau ou le mouton mais
c'est souvent aussi sa boisson mais
c'est souvent fait aussi de façon
végétarien nos têtes raides que même la
plupart des talent il y restera qui se
spécialise en italie en nc des
restrictions uniquement végétarien déjà
c'est bon les épices et foule
qu'est ce qu'on a dans les yeux donc ici
j'ai cuisiné vraiment à les recettes
mêmes qui ont certes pas ça dans la
société comme paiement spécial
c'est dans la cuisine de sa mère que
meola appris à faire à manger dans sa
famille le talent y c'est un seul grand
couvert partager c'est vraiment juste
l'assiette puis après ça on utilise les
petits ball le nom alain s'évade qui
coûtera 10 et batterie dans une assiette
aux mains de plusieurs petits ball
donc qu'est ce qu'on a ici on à le
supplanter ça c'est le dal sasso faire
ma famille donc ça c'est vraiment comme
un sou mais on utilise le dal aussi dans
la fille aussi j'ai un peu mélangé et
ici on a le pomme de terre c'est cuit
avec un petit kimbuta et de tous mais
ici on à leur état comme j'ai dit ça
c'est comme le teddy qui est bien c'est
fait avec le yo gourd le cocon de la
mode a encore donc le thalys a inclus le
entrer des fois jusqu'au les dessins des
foires aux connaisseurs jusqu'au des
dessins
vraiment le concept cité comme
je suis fille en laine il ya beaucoup de
personnes c'est toujours à chante donc
quand tu allais à l'heure est aux
commandes du rallye
c'est tout ça vient avec tout donc je
peux manger en 15 à 20 minutes 5
l'utopique fini tu vas les bars pour le
jour de fête au restaurant bouche ap
il n'est pas rare de voir des clients
manger leur tally en moins de vingt
minutes
le thalys les plus populaires rapport à
ceux restant alors sud est
l'asim à sion ces camps à peu près 200
par jour
c'est ma mère qui fait la cuisine et
mère mon père aussi a perdu mon père
faire les plusieurs décès ici pas de
poulet au beurre
la philosophie de la famille a toujours
été de servir un talus authentique du
punjab donc intelli végétarienne et à
faible coût
c'est que les prix sont abordables alors
et le goût c'est comme très proche de m
nous le moment j'ai toujours commence
avec la soupe sur pourquoi
puis après ça vous pu goûter tout mais
quand c'est tout tout est content quand
vous tous les assiettes on peut mélanger
dans la vie où on peut mais fait des
mélanges vraiment dépenses on vous
attend qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire aussi
et maintenant savent les saveurs on va
mettre les chauffeurs
on va mettre le chou vert maître dans
l'art y ajouter un peu des dalles
blanches
mais c'est ça
[Musique]
c'est bon un peu piquant peut nous on a
les faveurs des épices féliciter votre
mère a bien montré
[Musique]